today we are going to be eating some
Whitnall more food but we have a couple
of special guests that actually one of
them is not going to teach me how to do
[ __ ] she's just there just eat the food
she's [ __ ] useless right there and
then we have Lynn so Lynn is a VIP
Vietnam when you call specialist what
are we cooking we're gonna make a dish
called it watching bug what the [ __ ]
hahahaha the transition was crazy I
actually never had this it I use a lot
of it nummies food but I never had this
David himself was like such a food
critic I'm not a food critic oh if I
were the body Oh somebody can critique
food these are these are all friends
from Sacramento we I've known her since
she was a little baby I think she was
like 16 years old at the time when I
first met her and look at her she's a
full-blown oh I'm excited to eat I know
that's what I came here for later on I'm
gonna make her sing for you guys
pictures amazing singers with damage
though oh you're not gonna I'm not doing
is we're gonna go to the supermarket to
pick the ingredients for the food that
we're going to be making and going to be
eating and we have art once again our
Vietnam specialist tic tac no buck
ping-pong
I have a genius genius videographer
b-boy extraordinaire well apparently I
didn't know can actually break into
houses what do we have here Vince
cameraman just breaking the house kids
don't try this at home nothing unethical
let them round here just the half white
half asian man break into his own home
eluded Lulu it turns out this is an
amazing burglar which is just a skill
that I'm kind of scared of right papa
are you proud of your video man I am the
fact that he's a [ __ ] criminal I had
no idea and as soon photo [ __ ] home
invasion [ __ ]
I'm absolutely surprised huh Allan day's
work you know the funny thing is like
with me I know for a fact and if this
happened to me I was just been like
locksmith [ __ ] but you just
never gave up you are a true man's man
what is supermarket love affair so it's
this lovely story where this girl thinks
that she falls in love with this guy
actually she does fall in love with this
guy that she bumps into at the
supermarket he turns around and gives
her at the sweetest smile in the
detergent aisle then you
yes she's crazy to say I love you
he's quoting the lyrics right now that's
how much she has watched that video and
listened to that song crazy do you think
I love you supermarket
what did you see it like that it sounds
good
when I met do you I almost missed you
once again this is how much she's listen
to the song growing up because she's
getting angry that I don't even live as
if it's a legitimate song when I missed
you met you met you I almost missed you
well have you stood right
when I met you I almost missed you as
you stood right next to me in the are
between the touch ins in love just in
front of eastern me you we are finally
here at a shun fat supermarket
it's mainly gonna be beef and then we're
gonna have some shrimp and squid or do
you like sleep I love Sunday so high in
protein low in fat but not so greater
the cholesterol like mo see it's okay
you could have dietary cholesterol if
you're gonna do the calculus cholesterol
don't you [ __ ] better into us
Vietnamese cuisine has a lot of herbs so
we're gonna do a lot of herbs and fresh
vegetables in spring rolls we're making
single spring roll now every time I go
to the corner
I just keep thinking you be
yes is crazy to think I love you
supermarket love
traditionally in almost every single
like Chinese cuisine ajussi that'll be
like onions and ginger in it this [ __ ]
looks like a deformed moose knuckle
we're gonna buy some mushrooms
in the air rifle mushroom kingpin
mushrooms but I'm actually looking for
King oyster you have an Asian
supermarket around you guys make sure
you let you go there for your produce
number one because it's cheaper number
two they have a lot more [ __ ] at number
three nobody speaks English sure so you
won't be bothered
this interestingly enough is not ginger
is called Kallang wall I guess this is a
lot of Thai cuisines and a lot of the
cookbooks or or stuff that I've read
when I try to make Thai food they always
tell you to replace kalach all if you
can't find a with ginger but this tastes
different it's not as harsh as ginger
that's why I cook [ __ ] what's up
what what what I work having the jaws of
a sec stomach ache later better grab an
apple an orange
Oh better sharp what is it oh no this is
very shot you [ __ ] me over Mintz leave
that [ __ ] damn charge except it's a boat
egde one thing I can recognize is MSG
aka the reason why all y'all [ __ ] tastes
good and it actually comes a lot of
natural things such as kelp see me kombu
naturally has msg that's why you always
see that in that little dashi box they
kind of throw that little seaweed event
makes it extra tasty we're looking for
brown rice noodles yeah and it blends
personal favorites
it's healthier why does it help you cuz
it's a brown rice versus refined white
rice brown rice has nutreve white rice
just has whiteness what's wrong with
whiteness everything Coronel that is a
Korean Spanish
yep got a menudo if we can cook for you
we can make your [ __ ] noodles to
bottle okay we [ __ ] come over I see
these fusion trucks all the time you put
a taco and some curry in me [ __ ] you
[ __ ] [ __ ] that [ __ ] man [ __ ] make
your noodle in a better than you
thank you so if you go to a butcher
unlike most commercial supermarkets that
you go to they'll actually slice it and
prepare the way that you want so we got
the beef around and we needed it thinly
sliced so they did it for us love these
guys I'm going to marry into their
family we all know the class I think you
learn vanilla clams and I love fresh
oysters it's an aphrodisiac what does
that mean it means that you gonna have
sex later